hi I'm maxley and I'm nine years old
today Two Chefs are going to compete to
make my dream Pokemon dish
what's up
what's up oh and nice to meet you hi I'm
actually I'm age hi I'm actually I'm a
food content creator based out of Los
Angeles and I specialize in sandwiches
I'm so pumped to be on this competition
and even more pumped to be cooking
alongside my dear friend H Wooley so if
you were a Pokemon
what would you eat first oh we got the
berries so yellow berries yep are the
Pokemon super hungry today probably they
haven't even eaten I am a food content
creator and this is my first time on I
draw you cook I feel like especially
with Owen it's not really competition
it's just for fun I will still win no we
need the cake so these are layers right
yes they are layers okay and now what is
that uh it's just the markings and stuff
do you like sweets oh yeah yeah a little
a little hesitant there so you're more
Savory or a little bit of both a little
bit of both do you have a favorite fruit
from banana okay so Banana is your
favorite yes yes this cake was supposed
to be given by Arceus so it's a revive
for all the Pokemon it's kind of like
that because there's like a full restore
yeah it's kind of like a full restore I
feel like he and I are connecting on
some level of Pokemon I got some of the
references so do you have a favorite
food
it's a Hawaiian food what are your other
types of favorite foods chicken cutlet
you have a favorite kind of sushi oh
yeah California roll what's your
favorite vegetable broccoli all right so
what is this blue thing it's called
Ocean Mist it's a quench to The Thirst
of the Pokemon yes I mean yeah like if
he's eating a cake this big he needs a
lot of liquid you are correct I'm kind
of a little nervous just because there's
so many colors going on and immediately
I'm seeing a very big cake and I don't
bake whatsoever all right so we got some
star action going here yep so what is
that for no they eat it like regular
food like the cake so do you think we
can actually make this Pokemon dish into
what you want yeah I think so good luck
to both of you
[Music]
I'm going to start with a tiered banana
bread cake because Max's favorite fruit
is banana I am making sushi rice for the
first layer of cake which is going to be
layered with other components of Max's
favorite food Loco Moco
I'm very worried I was also thinking of
making a loco moco I thought it was a
great idea it hits right on the spot of
what his favorite food is you start with
sushi grain rice I will start it and
then get on to my next layer of the cake
the chicken cutlet layer of the cake
that's not in a normal local okay if you
remember I don't said his other favorite
food was chicken cutlet that's true I'm
adding all those favorite foods is this
your mom's recipe it is damn it it's
really good she makes it really good
banana bread truthfully I'd never make
sweets except for ice cream but you want
to wait no I don't okay
this is my impression of how Owen Cooks
but for this time I would like to make a
banana bread cake I feel like I cook
pretty fast I get the job done it's very
free-flowing he's loud and big and
that's reflective of his personality as
well you gotta be honest I'm like really
bad at one hand cracking eggs pretty
good at it I know pretty much every way
there is to crack an egg so you take one
egg you take another egg and you crack
the egg on the other egg look at that
have a little fun with it you know crack
the eggs against each other
do two hands watch this
with the eggs thoroughly baking soda
salt white sugar brown sugar vanilla
paste canola oil buttermilk secret
ingredient wet batter dry batter combine
it all together I'm just gonna kind of
fold it in so once you don't really see
too many clumps of flour then you can
start pouring it into your pre-greased
cake molds then we'll bake these off
have you cooked for kids a lot no you no
but I consider myself a kid and I cook
for myself every day got it so yes so
now we're gonna shallow fry you want to
drop it away you're looking for a nice
golden brown and then you're gonna flip
it three to five minutes per side so for
the next part of the drawing these five
little star boys are gonna be
star-shaped chicken nuggets I love
chicken nuggets season our ground
chicken paprika some onion powder garlic
powder black pepper and some salt we got
a nice golden brown and we're just gonna
set that aside let it rest season it
thank you of course now we're gonna get
started on the the locomoco beef patty
okay so we're gonna crack two eggs in
here mix it all together you've got your
wonderful mixture and bang flying it out
so we got ground beef chopped up onion
two eggs panko garlic oyster sauce
Worcestershire
filio's pretty good this is pretty good
really bind the ingredients together
we're gonna take this ring mold and
shape the meat once we have it nice and
compact in its Perfect Circle we're
gonna go bake it it's looking good you
think that looks good there's just a
layer of chicken sludge I'm gonna go
freeze this lettuce set now we're gonna
make the gravy for the Loco Moco so
we're going to start by melting some
butter in a pot we're gonna saute the
mushrooms I have some washed cleaned
rice here a cup of fresh mountain spring
water that's a lie that's not a lie I
saw you get it from this I never lie you
got it from the sink no I did it I'm
gonna make some sushi rice that looks
familiar wait what is the rice for I
don't know Max they loved Ritz crackers
so I'm gonna batter my chicken and
nugget stars in Ritz cracker
dude it's a Mullen
you want to find dust now that my
mushrooms are nice and cooked we'll add
the beef stock and then that corn starch
slurry so it's very liquidy now but give
it like five minutes and you'll have
your gravy glue Blended Ritz crackers
Over Batter I'll put a little paprika
here but at the end we're gonna dust it
with fresh ketchup powder look at that
that's some good gravy nice and thick
and glossy we can let this go and cool
the rice has been cooked so we'll add it
to a bowl
and then add the seasonings rice vinegar
sesame oil salt and sugar mix it all up
so it'll be nice Compact and sticky put
it on a sheet tray and evenly
distribute it you can be messy just keep
it on your side that's all yeah but like
come on there's like a few grains of
rice Messi's not bad
but he's messier than me flatten it
we're gonna freeze this cut it and fry
it and we're gonna start my Sushi balls
I knew you're mixing I'm dicing up very
finely some avocado so I'm gonna cut
these cucumbers into fine little stems
so they look like the tops of berries
and this is something I'm still working
on but you can skin a cucumber pressing
down
small cuts
you can rotate the Cucumber so you get
your skin off why do you have to
complicate everything let me like take
out my tweezers and be all nitpicky so
cucumbers looking pretty stemmy I have
puff pastry so I'm going to start by
Rolling it out I'm gonna cut out shapes
kind of struggling here I'm having a
little trouble cutting out the stars
look at this star like what what is this
but I did hear a great tip on flowering
the mold so it just slides right out oh
look at that it worked it worked that's
perfect you got it now we're gonna brush
this with egg wash this will be a good
binder for the parmesan that we're going
to sprinkle on top I'm gonna go bake
them hopefully the shape will hold for
the last component of the California
roll imitation crab and I'm just gonna
do a little test because this is my
first time making California rolls but
I'm gonna try to bind avocado with the
imitation crab with a little mayo now
that the rice has cooled and set I'm
going to be using these two shapes to
cut out of the layers of the cake
I'm like scared so I've never made a
rice Patty this big and I'm definitely
struggling to get it inside the pot put
it put it flat on The Cutting Board
plastic going just needing my health
again this way I'm gonna flip it over
right now how's my hand supposed to flip
that way he's always there for me when I
need him no but like
there and then take the paper off thank
you all right gently slide it in away
from you
yeah
my California roll mixture is done I'm
gonna start seasoning my rice dude
rice vinegar salt sugar I will say this
worries me seeing him make rice because
to be honest the best sushi rice I've
ever had is from H making sure every
grain is coated it's a little too
seasoned but
it's like juicy it's too much vinegar
that was not the rice I was talking
about no I'm just not in my element this
is like not my rice cooker nor the right
amount I use can I please borrow some of
your rice so you want to take some of my
rice I was a little taken aback when H
asked to use my rice to make his rice
better but since he lended me a hand in
getting the rice in the fryer I'm
obviously gonna help them out yeah yeah
okay thank you this is looking great we
got that nice Golden Crust on the
outside so we're just going to transfer
it over and let it drain and cool so now
we're gonna form our yellow Sushi Bowl
Berry thing to make it yellow we're
going to use Yuzu or yellow topico so
our base layer you gotta be very gentle
with this stuff I think H is taking a
big risk with these Sushi balls he's
covering it in fish eggs I don't know
what nine-year-old likes that next layer
is rice it's a little bit of our filling
a little bit more rice to seal that so
you pull this all together
and try to get all the air out and
you're going to twist and form a sushi
ball unravel this puppy I'm gonna add a
little stems that ain't look at that
that ain't it it's cute that is not a
yellow bear this is an interpretation I
think it looks more like a yellow brain
either way it doesn't look that great
but when you put the little stem on top
I think it looks cute now I'm going to
show you how to make real yellow berries
so we're going to start by cleaning up
the pineapple I have this ring mold that
kind of resembles like a berry shape oh
that's pretty cool so I am making
punctures in the pineapple to put in the
little airhead stems my chicken has
frozen I'm gonna punch them out with
these star shapes flour egg wash Ritz
cracker breadcrumb all right so now we
have our puff pastry Stars these are
great look at that now we just gotta
turn them red and so to do that we have
even more cheese mix that with some red
food coloring and then we're just gonna
coat it toss it and that's a red cheese
star look at that that looks radioactive
why does it look like a nuclear power
plant he may think it's radioactive I
think maxley will think it looks
identical to the picture bang fry dude
look at that
it's pretty cool my final stage I'm
gonna dust this ketchup powder Bang
red stars that aren't radioactive dude
that looks just as normal as my banana
bread cake is done so I'm just cutting
off the top to flatten it and create my
three-tiered banana bread cake I'm gonna
be shaving off some vegetables got a
bunch of different colors here yellow
strips purple cabbage green we're gonna
use his favorite vegetable good old
broccoli look at that that looks sick
that's a cake I am not an expert at
frosting your mom is a great baker my
mom is a Great Baker
I do know H's mom quite well uh she
would uh
hi Susan no they they get along well
they get along really well so we're
gonna start off with our Ocean Mist
right now I have a bunch of delicious
ingredients here all natural what's that
over there all right hear me out kids
love all of this we got ingredients for
a Mountain Dew Baja Blast and now to
make this magical drink add some honey
around the rim roll it in some pop rocks
and even ratio of Mountain Dew and
Sprite and then the rest will be frost
cool Gatorade and then uh this is blue
and it's sugar so I'm gonna put it
inside the cup as well there you have it
blue Misty uh
drink so to make this Ocean Mist Misty
and oceany of Spirulina powder my man
with your plate he's eating chicken
nuggets whole cake Sushi balls he's
gonna be quite parched and does he want
to like take down a thick Shake no he's
gonna want some nice
cool Misty Mountain Dew Baja Blast you
know that's my thought process you do
you my thought process was nailing each
component I don't think that a
nine-year-old is going to think about
the balance of an entire composed dish
all right drinks are done let's uh plate
up and present it yeah Chef my burger
patty shrunk significantly so I'm gonna
have to basically shrink everything else
to make sure it has that tear layer for
the cake first thing I'm going to deal
with is decorating my banana bread cake
so I'm gonna first measure some of these
Twizzlers to line up the tiered cake
yours is a lot more difficult the gravy
glue seems to be working nice it's also
gonna be very flavorful and now I'm just
gonna cut a mold for the chicken and the
last part is just a fried egg look at
that that's a Savory cake you think when
Maxi tries your cake he's gonna think
Loco Moco I really hope so so now we're
going to decorate said cake it's the
cake for the Pokemon God realizing
though that I need to decorate a bit
more than I thought
this cake looks pretty plain we'll add
the red stars so he has a few red
stripes on there I'm gonna just try to
make a few red lines with ketchup surely
for spacing I chose this really big lazy
Susan
because this cake is what's a lovely
Susan it's the term for this it's a lazy
excuse me yeah it's your mom's name it
is my red stars on the plates my yellow
berries and my wonderful Ocean Mist
milkshake and I am done all right well
let's see what maxley thinks and may the
best cook win
overall I'm super happy with the entire
Dish as a whole really stoked with how
the cake turned out I think you can
clearly see each layer and the different
colors the red stars I think are
identical they also taste great the blue
drink I think is also super cool give
them that mist effect it's blue it's
sweet it's sugar what more do you want
the berries it is just pineapple but I
added the green AirHeads hopefully he
will be a fan of that I think it looks a
lot like the picture I hope Maxie likes
it too I'm feeling pretty good about
this dish starting with the cake I think
it looks great I think it looks like the
picture even though it's not a perfect
oval with a hundred colors the yellow
berries I think they look adorable and
they honestly look like something out of
Pokemon he likes chicken cutlets I think
chicken nuggets hit the spot Ocean Mist
tastes great I feel like every single
kid in the world loves vanilla
milkshakes hopefully maxley enjoys my
plate more than Owens and and I can take
home the prize bring on my dream Pokemon
dish
oh my God they actually went full out on
the
one they're supposed to be green not
purple actually I tried my best with the
colors I just give me a break and they
actually um did the umbrella I think
I'll eat the Stars that's chicken
I'm wondering now what is the red
[Music]
it actually does taste good
[Music]
I don't really like it oh my God he
didn't like the sushi balls what are
they just take a bite in the Middle with
your favorite California roll wait a
minute
what is inside
[Music]
it tastes like my dad's coffee with
frosting on it why is he drinking his
dad's coffee the cakey itself is okay in
the middle the color is actually
bringing a little bit up overall I think
the drink is what is keeping it up I'm
gonna lose
I can't believe this it kind of looks
very close to it how did they get the
eggs so small he seemed stoked they kind
of burnt it a little
[Music]
tastes lemony it tastes okay
hurricane is really hard to bite in
that's Pop Rocks I think we'll try the
star it's hard or kind of
what is this it's cool
and elbow hey they actually do look like
it I think I'm definitely getting more
points on accuracy I think I'll try this
cake
oh I know what this is the local Marco
that's actually pretty good that is
chicken the Red Chicken was better he's
as smart as I thought he's good
I knew it it was pineapple everything
mixed well with the pineapple overall
the cake was pretty good and also the
pineapple let's bring on the chefs
foreign
good all right Max Lee which dish did
you like more Dish One or dish two
Dish One
yeah I won
thank you thank you thank you thank you
for being on with me and also baking me
the greatest lunch ever oh thank you
that was really sweet it's the greatest
achievement of my entire life congrats H
Wu maxley I hope you enjoyed your food
and um I'll see you in fourth grade do I
get a consolation prize
yeah a hug oh come here maxley can I get
a hug yeah sure oh thank you very much
for letting me like eat what you made
it's my honor it's not your honor
you can say to do it
[Music]